this is eight news now two disabled
veterans on a fixed income didn't know
what to do when their catalytic
converter was stolen this week so eight
news now finley kia and a local muffler
shop teamed up to help them orco mana
shared this heartwarming story that
you'll only see right here on eight news
now
two veterans in dire need and a
community stepping up to help that's the
story of james and chris a story that
has truly made a difference
a loud noise signaling a stolen
catalytic converter roommates james
swain and chris spiro two disabled
veterans with limited mobility stuck at
their apartment with no way to get
groceries or go to the doctor it was so
stressful you know all i did was want to
sleep photographer justin grant and i
first introduced you to james and chris
on thursday they couldn't afford to
replace the catalytic converter on their
kia sportage after it was sawed off
earlier in the week but that's when 8
news now stepped in to help
so much
we reached out to finley kia who started
finding a solution to give back to two
veterans who sacrificed so much for all
of us the ability to help them and what
it's going to do for their day moving
forward
it's irreplaceable the catalytic
converter that was needed was
discontinued by the manufacturer
but fiddly kia used their connections
with best muffler shop to find the
correct car part
sparks flying as the converter was put
into place the muffler shop doing it all
for free good that we can help somebody
out you know especially someone in need
they got they can't get around they need
their car you know we got help out
after a complimentary car service and
cleanup at findlay kia it was time to go
back to james and chris's apartment
oh my god a sigh of relief and a feeling
of gratitude you guys are great thank
you so much thank you thank you
thank you glad we could help two heroes
now able to move forward so much thanks
to channel 8 and the findlay
people for doing this for us what you
and channel 8 did it's just unbelievable
i can't thank you enough even in the
darkest times there are bright lights
willing to help we still have good
people in this community we got so many
emails and tweets from you our viewers
who wanted to help james and chris are
thankful for your support orco mana live
local now